my mother once asked me what I wanted to
be when I grow up I said happy she cried
for a week I wants to a picture of
Winnie the Pooh's sodomizing an
orangutan that was the last time I ever
talked in a gun art a woman once told me
that we are all unique beautiful and
wonderful snowflakes every one of us to
which I has to if we are all unique
beautiful wonderful snowflakes doesn't
that technically me we're all the same
she later shot herself in the bathroom
the hokey-pokey is a lie one day I would
like somebody to write my autobiography
and just to make it more confusing I'd
make sure he has the same name I do I
have decided that Twilight is the best
movie ever made even though I have never
seen it it's that good I often like to
write poetry and crime one day I hope to
combine the two together and one element
simply called cria tree the only
downside is people would think I'm some
sort of environmental is crying for
trees and I hate whole life people often
ask me if I'm an atheist
and I say no I don't believe they exist
I have discovered that I am addicted to
absolutely no addictions I'm a sober
holic I wish I knew how to play guitar
and writes all I knew someone who worked
at a suicide hotline once he hanged
himself I've often been told that if
life gives you lemons simply make
lemonade but what if life gives you
lemons and that eating green M&Ms makes
you horny do you want to know what makes
me horny porn
I am emo Jones it is my crime it is also
my punishment